I don't love how much I'm hearing the
term martial law I don't love that tell
you that much
you're hearing it a lot now gavin newsom
governor of california brought it up
hearing it the press is bringing it up
when you hear something like that over
and over again it feels like they're
doing a soft launch for martial law you
know feels like they're just do it a
little roll out see how you see how you
react to the idea you can't do things
like that all at once because it
inspires widespread panic and chaos
suspending the Constitution and bringing
in the military that tends to make
people a little iffy so what they do I
think is they introduce you to the
concept little by little a little
shelter in place a little shutdown and
we start seeing people at public parks
people working out people doing things
people still gathering together in
groups and the government goes you know
I don't know if we're gonna be able to
weather the storm here without the tank
we might need the tank to come in and
stop you from gathering in a park you
know I'm no fan of martial law I do
understand the shelter in place you know
and when I when I criticize the
conspiracy community for saying that the
virus isn't real or the virus is just
the flu or the virus is a cover so that
the government can arrest Tom Hanks
what I what I do fully understand and am
quite aware of is that when you have a
problem like this like 9/11 which is so
big and new that you are going to have
elements of the government and the
private sector you're going to have
people you know asrama might as rahm
emanuel
said he was the chief of staff for
Barack Obama and who is now the mayor of
Chicago or was I believe he still is the
mayor of Chicago as he said never let a
crisis go to waste
so there are going to be people that try
to take the few remaining rights you
have so you have to be a little vigilant
that doesn't mean you go COFF down an
old person's throat does it mean you
know you ignore what's a clear reality
which is this is a you know incredibly
dangerous virus but it means you're
vigilant and you understand that no
government has ever emerged from a
crisis with less power doesn't happen
does it happen the government now is
growing in power it's going to start to
pay you to live to stay home to sit in
your house it's gonna cut you a check
yet you don't have and by the way I'm
for that people need that but just let's
think about this let's zoom out for a
little bit and when we look at this we
we go you are now dependent on the
government for everything for everything
they've taken your ability in the short
term to earn a living and we understand
that in the short term I understand the
need to close things and I've told
people to comply with this but there
does come a point where you're going to
see you know it's kind of like when you
bring a car in to a mechanic and the
mechanic is less than reputable and you
know they're like it's totaled you know
we just we go we totaled out the car you
know you bring it in you know because
your headlights out and they look good
totaled you might as well
we're totalling the economy right now
the world economy I mean we are totaling
the world economy we are seeing a global
depression take root we are seeing
potentially unemployment in the range of
20% containment has failed the reports
now out of New York and California if
you have symptoms do not get tested
unless you are in a very high-risk group
and you're so sick that you have to go
to the hospital they are saving the
tests for health care workers doctors
nurses first responders people that are
coming in contact with this virus and
with sick people all the time so could
at that point when you say testing we
can't test anybody the containment model
which is based on knowing who has this
and who doesn't you know trying to
contain it you know the social
distancing the shelter in place you know
all of that
you know might have some positive effect
hopefully it does but a lot of people
are skeptical at this point about how
much of a positive effect it will have
we should still do it we should still do
it for the time being but I think a lot
of people are saying you got to move
into mitigation which is basically the
development the rapid development of
antiviral drugs you know they're talking
about chloroquine or something I think I
believe that's the name that was used to
fight malaria but I was reading about
those the side effects on that last
night it could be blindness and if you
take an extra dose sudden death they got
it
yeah chloroquine in yeah if you take a
sudden if you take an extra dose of that
goodbye so I don't know if that's the
best idea to give to old people I
imagine that that'll be given to them in
a hospital you take that with a riff
from iesson which is a z-pack to get
bronchitis you take a z-pack little
erythromycin take the five-day
you know - on the first day and then
boom boom boom boom boom and it usually
clears bronchitis so if you take the
chloroquine on for malaria and the
arrest from ice and it is beating back
the virus I have a friend who's a doctor
at Lenox Hill Hospital who said that
actually the results are pretty good